[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause] [Applause
] [Applause] [Applause
] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause
] [
Applause] [
Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music]
[Music]
[Music  ]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
turn your head Luca Let's go hole
perfectly
mother
storms
are dogs emotion
dogs emotion take aubergines
[Applause] [
Applause] [
Applause]
[Applause]
Mmm little piece
this bottom yours  watch out with your
mature ones so much so that
now for Missoni it prohibits in the
enormous expense
[Applause]
big calendar [
Applause]
[Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [
Applause] [Music
]
[Music]
[Music  ]
[Music] [
Music] [Music] [
Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[  Applause]
Berisha
look pyromi
Look gatta proud
both at gimosa
and the sacrastinians
was Berisha
Johann God
[Applause]
[Music] [
Music] [
Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [
Applause]
[Applause]
[Music  ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music] [
Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause
]
[Applause]
ah ah show show show
yes I disappeared
Ok that's really bad but
[Applause]
it's just yesterday
no even Halloween
everyone came down as a menu If you look it was born and
it swells
and what a taste
too down there
still on the lake how can I have
calmed down
[Applause] [Applause
]
Well done well done
[Applause]
professor professor
[Applause  ]
[Music]
[Applause]
this takes my savings and
requests little spider another weeper
from the island I want to do Animation for
all the vitamins and tannins warehouses of
Cooks and generous acid glassware return
here I'll put you  inside
Transformers
Simone eh Look how they say it
hurts me challenge there are those who try outworld
nothing I think in the resistances rifle
woodsmedance everything will be fine
I can do it with the eye shadows
Sprint routine
of theory experience.com
[Applause]
they sell the tiles here it holds  windy
I fear the automilmes went to go
then I come You who finger the salmon then
gave €100 in projection for the existence
passion of the potentials the package
fisworth
shikakawa
the symphony Yes immediately the
middle title is composed Therefore fringuette
in the existence  of the surim The Spirit I
talk about it as well as hot SMAT Land me the
Porsche you are cut a compass me a
site Paco Fisola da pietto sculpture
take
sure
this eye to the Cash flag
indreator if you come to voice Model within the
next good and my palette I like
sponsor 80 cubarella
[Applause]
Alice Matt di Piano
galina fananozzi But it's already hatching
[Applause]
[Music] [
Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause]
[Applause] [Applause  ]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[  Music]
[Music
] [Music] [
Music] [
Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [Music] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Dina sisoni
Lisa  is my year Thank you
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Music]
[Applause] [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ok I took the
house further back
Ok  to yours but Venier
Sports Creations Store
actress
Alissa my life
[Music]
the hoops
no careful friends
[Music] [
Music]
enter Yeti
Oh Anna tatankai [
Music]
incredible [
Music] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
of Olgiata
a path for cooked Jannacci
[Applause]
[Music] [
Music] [
Applause] [Music] [Music] [
Music]
turn tonight
[Music]
here
and bnmor the sun more
oh  oh oh oh oh
oh
Spain two more kit
challenges
Rossi
is of course there
turns Barone
Tahiti
every Special
Rina Maccioni
there is maturing to Sara bucioia
raise the
veranda garlic
well ripe
perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
from Lina zanahostess Pierce
tiraca
Vai Nicola
and Elisa thighs
Angy petucci
hoia H
tationate
the world YouTube
[Applause]
and accrued prices I read
Leonida
cuttini
in Rome You
made me in front of Lisa cusari
[Applause]
we the vulgar
enormous
photographs
and we come where we review driving
and then Bruna crowns
Hello Pier Berisha
[Applause]
the  I recommend Javier
Germaine de Ciro he doesn't
eat very well who stops me for
class so
[Applause]
[Applause] [Applause]
[Music] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause] [Applause
]
[Applause]
Go to paper
[Music]
Well done well done I
found myself strange guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music] [Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[  Music]
Come on Come on come on Rai 1 come on the
Girls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[  Music]
[Applause]
then
you matured awake all people giltan
crepes NaturHouse Rossi understand believe
here the stalker mom moments You
already have hair now
let's see
soon Hi guys we
also need to go straight to the freezer he gives them
the indirissums that is blackberry herbal tea weighs and
I say Mimi season Roadster Squad
together with half that between practically
used it For me
yes stop philade Maira helicopters takes
out
and is infamous for him so you understand
But the memories with a break back oh oh oh eh oh
oh
3 4 3 3
2 1
[Applause  ]
[Music]
on the sky Thank you
[Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [Music
] [
Music] [Music
] [Music
] [
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[  Music]
attention tender silence
[Music]